hay palabras y también diferentes vídeos
que exploran lo que la gente hacen la
oscuridad
Se abrazan se exploran
exploran su sexualidad lo que sienten en
el fondo de su alma
[Música]
en este opus de alta costura verano 2023
descubriremos un lado oculto de los
diseñadores la exploración que conduce a
la creación Iván es un joven ucraniano
que lleva 10 años en el negocio produce
casi exclusivamente piezas de alta
costura hechas a medida su investigación
se centra en nuestra propensión a
descubrir la fuente de nuestros deseos
más profundos pero no solo sexuales
interactuando con los demás la ropa
tanto para mujeres como para hombres es
siempre extremadamente sensual sin caer
nunca en la vulgaridad salgamos de las
profundidades del alma humana para
zambullirnos de lleno con la diseñadora
holandesa Iris van hardent
esta colección trata de la emancipación
de la mujer
quería expresarlo en un escenario que me
permitiera con la mayor precisión
posible
es llegar al meollo de la cuestión y
quería trabajar con alguien que
realmente encarnara esta fuerza femenil
San Juan
había visto el trabajo de Julia
Gutiérrez hace unos años y me inspiro
mucho
luego tuvo otro sueño durante mucho
tiempo
hacer una colecta para el espacio
lugares sin gravedad como el mar o las
profundidades marinas
[Música]
el agua es como el objetivo de una
cámara los colores son más vivos
las texturas más vivas
fue todo un reto a diseñar una colección
para este entorno
inspira mucho las aguas profundas de
hecho fue algo muy especial integrar
este entorno en mi proceso creativo
[Música]
viaja por el mundo para encontrar los
puntos en común entre la cultura
japonesa y otras culturas tradicionales
lo hizo durante un viaje al continente
africano donde se dio cuenta entre otras
cosas de que la alta costura como hemos
visto podía vestir tanto a mujeres como
a hombres
por supuesto tanto hombres como mujeres
el kimono japonés No tiene género
es la misma forma para hombres y mujeres
una forma rectangular
y también fui a Kenia el pasado octubre
para reflexionar sobre el futuro de la
industria de la moda
en Kenia África algunas prendas
tradicionales para envolver el cuerpo
tienen forma rectangular
así el kimono japonés y el traje
tradicional africano confluyen
este viaje me causó una gran impresión y
me inspiró mucho
también fui a la montaña de residuos de
nairobic
una creación humana
así que mezclé todo esto
La parte positiva de lo humano hice una
selección y la plasmé en mi colección
con los diseñadores de moda holandeses
Víctor y rolf la exploración se sitúa en
un nivel completamente distinto llamaron
a su colección el vals de la fase
avanzada del capitalismo el Dúo siente
el mismo placer jugando con las palabras
que con unas tijeras para jugar
simultáneamente con la ironía
bueno esa es una Concepción Absurda del
estereotipo de lo vulgar todos tenemos
esta imagen en la cabeza
ya ves las grandes faldas los hermosos
colores
eso nos gusta nos encanta el glamur pero
también el concepto de glamo
en cuanto al francés Alexandre boutier
se planteó una cuestión pragmática que
quieren las mujeres pero no todas las
mujeres solo aquellas que pueden
invertir en modelos de alta costura y
que no odian llevar pieles falsas porque
hay muchas pieles falsas para una
colección de verano La idea es que de
hecho existe una demanda al respecto
Tengo clientes que solían ir a
increíbles balnearios clásicos
mediterráneos o no a pasar los veranos
pero están cambiando un poco su destino
en verano van a lugares más
septentrionales casi fríos a 5 grados en
agosto hay una especie de pausa huyes de
la multitud huye del calor se están
creando nuevos destinos y de hecho
también hay que vestirlos se están
también hay que adornarlos es muy
interesante ver lo que ocurre después de
esta situación de covid en la que puntos
de referencia están un poco borrosos en
la que el mundo vuelve a empezar pero no
sabemos muy bien cómo un poco
angustiante en la que la gente con estas
redes sociales sugiere siempre las
mismas ciudades los mismos lugares sigue
habiendo una inversión de los
comportamientos bastante subterránea
bastante discreta y eso me parece
bastante interesante
el mundo que nos rodea Para proponer
cosas bellas divertidas absurdas o
incluso inútiles Esta es otra definición
de la alta costura